today's topic Lilly sings show just got
renewed and everyone on YouTube is J had
some reactions
make that into a gif I know you already
are this is gonna be a very disorganized
vlog we're having many thoughts and I'm
just getting a season two you should
offer because there we have imposed to
get on my Instagram my Twitter my
YouTube mmm mother - tinder everything I
really really do value time where I just
talk to you directly into the camera no
one else is here like there's no exacts
there's no teams just you and I and I
thought I would talk to you honestly and
genuinely about my late night show no BS
the top line I did season one we wrapped
it in December of last year and I just
got renewed for a season - that is gonna
be shot I don't know what quarantine my
overall thoughts and feelings are I am
so excited I am beyond honored I'd be
lying if I was like oh I'm just happy no
I'm freaking nervous if you like puking
all over again as if this is season one
all over as if I've never done this
before
I'm gonna puke you know as much as I'm
cringing right now when she's not doing
these corny jokes
she's actually slightly charismatic yo I
could see the potential yeah I could see
the potential yeah you understand
problem is you can't really work with
potential you have to work with actual
good he's not mean and as a thing yeah
if if it was just her talking and being
likable that that'd be fine but she has
corny corny corny jokes that she don't
need to do first time you introduced me
to this girl first thing I said was yo
she trying too much yeah
she doing too much she reaching yeah yo
I hope she said before she did that
reach she's reaching all the time and it
feels like it's unnatural that's what's
crazy about her it's just everything
feels unnatural
this is cringy but feels a bit more
natural
it's her engine pockets it's cringing
when she does those little pull aways
where she goes
but when she's just talking she's just
her there's elements that are good super
good elements but now she keeps on
wanting a pony stuff it's like if you do
a joke and I can call the punch at the
end because I know I mean even if it's
predictable can still be good it's just
sometimes it just sounds super heck
white man bad you know if I can
summarize your thing to just like basic
state it can get really redundant she's
Amy Schumer basically yes bisexual
person of coloring yes and that's not
good and that's the problem is Amy
Schumer had potential when she started
to be corny something to happen yeah
sure potential after she stole all those
drugs but again it comes back to the
other video that we did I ain't mad at
her I'm mad at the people who were
giving her that money I'm mad at you for
that yes she does the corny jokes and
yes she starts to bear some
responsibility for the things that say
it come out her mother who's giving her
this platform it's like when people get
mad at these a thoughts for doing
whatever they do when they're like give
me your money I deserve it and if you
don't you're a bad person well who are
the people who are giving these people
that money you did what I'm saying who's
the one that's giving her that supply
that's my question frankly she's like by
all judging like if you look at the
ratings I didn't do it exceptionally
well so what is the reason behind the
people bringing this person back that's
my main question now look I'm not gonna
hit on her - she got a second chance
good for her I hope she takes it and she
takes it far because I want to see
youtubers succeed on his platform that
being said judging by this video doesn't
seem like she's learned to downplay her
corniness at all which is like a big
factor of why she was terrible in the
first season forget the terrible one
there's some good show they've been
cancelled breath we do comedy festivals
and we see sometimes people who get on
galas and we hear other communes but how
could that person get booked they're
trashed don't get mad at them for taking
opportunities offered who booked these
people I know the gala comes out and
it's a terrible show and people were
like uh
I'm not mad at the comedians because
they're just being offered a lot of one
on a get paid you make a very good valid
point
there's more deserving people she didn't
make that choice they did and I don't
know too many people would pass on
millions of dollars to give another to
someone else because there's more
deserving people to million dollars like
matters people in need give it to them
no you take the money and run break it
down for you we shot 96 episodes in
three months and if you're thinking
that's a lot you're right well they
usually shoot year-round because of
budget and scheduling and just other
things I had going on in the year who
shot 96 episodes and three months and
let me just candidly tell you what that
was like very hard listen in the last
video we compared her to an open mic er
performing on national TV to know that
she didn't have much time in between
each show to prepare and to get ready it
makes it exponentially worse yeah it's
exactly that exponentially work as a
stand-up mean you go up to do a like
open micro show you get time afterwards
to prepare your material for the next
time you go around could be a month
before you go back to that same spot
with her she going up there multiple
knives at night yeah of course if she
was set up to fail of course the
delivery was whack the delivery was lame
all that was happy she didn't even have
time to prepare it everything I loved
about season one my team was amazing I
would have got insane if it wasn't for
my writers my producers my a V my AV I
own the audiovisual every person that
was part of season one I am saying
because of you truly including NBC
[Music]
I'm saying like it was fine
and then she did the weird again and
it's just like what are you appealing to
that's not a bit of that YouTube humor
though where they do a lot of like faces
and just transition like her and that
other one
what's that little brown girl Alyssa
Koecher what culture I know is salt she
does that too like that's her sense of
humor unless you got her TV show and she
tried to do the same stuff and it didn't
work it was a trend made me who I am I
can truthfully say they've always
supported Who I am as a person and for
that shout out shout out shout outs one
of the things I love most about season 1
was I feel like there's a lot of
episodes when I watch them back I was
like you know what
this right here is representation
episodes like myself and Mindy Kaling
like myself and Stephanie Beatrice like
myself in Cowpens where you're hearing
tamo words and Hindi words and Bollywood
movie references and two girls talking
about their sexuality I'm like you know
what I have never seen a conversation
like this online and it was so wonderful
for me to see comments and tweets from
you saying exactly that like I feel like
my TV's broke and I see three brown
people on my screen talking about things
I really do I can definitely understand
that and I can respect that problem is
when you want representation you also
want it to be well represented meaning
the first time I see an Ethiopian person
on the national stage maybe I don't want
to see them you know acting like it's a
World Vision commercial you dig what I'm
saying like how we're represented also
matters it's not just showing up at the
ball what you do there also matters it
by far the biggest win of season one was
how much I learned I feel like I learned
a lifetime of things yeah this was my
first time doing anything of this nature
I know about budgets about production of
this size about unions about standards
and practices about shoot schedules like
literally amateur it was a really great
experience and
I learned so much and I'm so incredibly
proud of what we were able to do
considering a lot of the challenges
associated with the show but now I'm
gonna just be real with you and telling
you the things that I think I can
improve on one of the things I pride
myself in is my self-awareness I think
I'm pretty good at being self-aware and
so I can truly sit here and tell you
that there were some episodes of the
show where I was like oh this is amazing
I was like the schedule didn't always
allow me to have a monologue that I was
a hundred percent about sometimes I
would feel a little about what the show
had to go on and yeah I'm well aware
that in some episodes I look hella
uncomfortable and you know what that's
probably because I am the truth is it
was my season one of doing something
brand new and season one really reminded
me a lot like first youtube video lil
you know everything takes time and takes
practice the difference is normally when
people have a first season it gets
cancelled you're being renewed so these
people are a reason to pause I've
watched plenty of TV shows that I loved
that I thought were great
and I did okay with ratings still got
shelved so when people see your first
season and they thought it was terrible
and they see it renewed there's reason
to understand why people might be like
oh and look you know another criticism
of her would be the fact that she's
unable to take any of this criticism and
that's fair you know she's they're not
able she says she is self-critical and
all this stuff but in one of the
comments she reads yeah I try not to
read any of it because you can't tell
the difference between hate and you know
real criticism yes you can there's a lot
to improve on and so when you give me
feedback why doesn't she have this guest
on the show why isn't she doing this
it's not for lack of trying
it's just I'm trying to figure it out so
many times have been tempted to respond
to comment so why isn't this person on
your shoulder like oh it's because
they're scheduled it's because they have
a PR team that does this
why don't you play this game on your
show Oh cuz legally we can't do that why
aren't you in more sketches because when
I shoot one for my YouTube channel it's
this much money when you shoot it for
the show it's this much money there are
so many things I have learned and I feel
like going into season 2 what I'm really
excited about is taking all that
knowledge all the times I've made
mistakes and stumbled and was confused
now I know all that stuff and if you
fail again then we'll know that you
really don't know there's a lot of
youtubers who try to venture off into
something new and they fail at first and
they start to build up some momentum and
they figure it out and I hope that's the
case for her I don't know do you think
get paid you say you have self-awareness
we'll see you say all this stuff and
everything's your second chance
yeah we'll see all about that that video
I can't gauge your corniness or no
you're gonna have the same writers or
whatever we're not how did Joseph MB
corny we'll see you made a valid point
so what's renewed there's nothing we
could do about that okay now you say you
know fair let's go we'll see
and look on topic of her doing these
jokes about white people in this and
stuff like that my stance on this is
pretty simple people should be able to
joke about anything and I get that it's
unfair that people can get away with
these white jokes on TV and you can do
the opposite a lot of ways I get it but
to me the solution is not to banish
people for making those white jokes the
goal would be to make everyone be able
to make all the jokes that's me person
all those matters yeah yes yeah any
other thoughts on this whole thing or
leasing this we'll see so yeah these are
my thoughts on this whole story but we
want to hear your thoughts guys so leave
your comment below and don't forget to
subscribe the page
[Music]